[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans ce set
8 les invités une émission dédiée à
celles et ceux qui font l'actualité dans
le département est aujourd'hui mercredi
1er février parole à bruno myle yens le
président du modem soit 118 la
représentation locale du parti de
françois bayrou qui organisait récemment
une conférence de presse en commun avec
lui dit l'occasion pour le centre de
faire le point sur les échéances locales
et nationales qui vont marquer l'agenda
des prochains mois paroles aussi dans
cette émission à sabine caussens la
directrice du prisme l encours et
coprésident du festival féminin pluriel
elle nous présentera les enjeux et les
objectifs de ce nouveau rendez vous
culture et dans les yvelines avec au
programme plus de 50 représentations
jusqu'au 1er avril politique donc pour
débuter cette émission et le centre qui
se rassemblent en tout cas à l'échelle
du département modem et udf viennent de
tenir une conférence de presse commune
pour célébrer 2010 est un temps des
changes pour débattre des enjeux locaux
mais aussi pour évoquer une possible
alliance en vue des prochaines élections
présidentielle et législatives écoutez à
ce propos
bruno milliers le président du modem 78
il était au micro de wilfrid richier le
modem éludé y ont donc décidé
d'organiser des voeux conjointe pour ce
début d'année vont soir bruno millet
bonsoir
pourquoi cette décision déjà tout
d'abord d'organiser une cérémonie un
petit peu comme ça informel de voeux
avec avec lui des modems ideye parce que
ça fait quand même assez longtemps que
le mot des mélodies discutent ensemble
on est deux familles centristes certes
séparés au national mais dont les dont
les valeurs sont assez communes même
très commune souvenez vous quand même
qu'on a fait les européennes ensemble et
ça a plutôt bien marché dans les ive et
puisqu'on a fait 15% je crois qu'on a
fait le meilleur score de l'île de
france est donc en discutant avec paul
ça fait longtemps qu'on discute et ça
fait longtemps qu'on se dit quand même
qu'on a toutes ces valeurs qu'on a en
commun il faudrait qu'on les porte sur
le territoire c'est vraiment pour le
territoire qu'on le fait
parce que la politique voyez bien la
politique au niveau national ça commence
à devenir un peu délétère il ya des
affaires qui sortent les uns les unes
derrière les autres et nous au niveau
territoire on veut aussi prouver aux
gens que il ya des élus sur le
territoire qui travaillent qui
travaillent pour les franciliens
en l'occurrence qui travaillent ici pour
les yvelinois et qui se préoccupe
vraiment des territoires et vous savez
ce qui à bâtir ya quand même les
communautés il ya la grosse communauté
urbaine gps et nos plus les communautés
de communes qui grandissent de plus en
plus il ya des choses à faire
très précise et très précisément avec
des visions et bien on les a en commun
et on veut les mettre en place le
positionnement aujourd'hui du modem
c'est quoi quand on voit un petit peu
comment les différentes choses se
positionne on entend parler de françois
fillon un petit peu impressionnant au
niveau national par exemple c'est
toujours il va forcément avoir une
incidence sur le local pour les
investitures pour les législatives
mais c'est toujours la même chose c'est
ça qui est compliqué à comprendre avec
nous les positions sont toujours les
mêmes le côté le côté on va libérer
l'économie ça tout le monde est d'accord
il faut libérer l'économie pour les
entreprises pour les entrepreneurs pour
les gens faut une claire moins de
bureaucratie parce qu'on en meure mais
il faut aussi la protection sociale il
faut aussi l'environnement
il faut aussi penser à la révolution
numérique de demain est ce qu'on va
faire des gens qui vont rester sur le
bord de la route pendant peut-être pas
très longtemps le temps le temps de la
transition se fasse non peut pas laisser
les laisser sur le bord de la route
et aujourd'hui je suis désolé de le dire
encore une fois françois fillon ne
répond pas à cette question pour nous en
tout cas nous on a toujours ce côté d'un
côté effectivement un petit peu
libéralisme
enfin du libéralisme pour libérer
l'économie les la paix aux jambes
ont donné de la liberté et de l'autre
côté la protection des plus précaires il
faut il faut il faut qu'on s'y attelle
et on n'y est pas pour l'instant donc
pour l'instant notre positionnement à
cheval il est où il est berrou east il
est en marche
pour l'instant non 10 à 30 et non mais
plus sérieusement forcément au début
tout le monde a pris un peu emmanuel
macron pour une espèce de bulle mais
médiatico politico on doute on ne savait
pas trop où elle allait on pensait que
ça allait exploser parce que ça
ressemblait trop un truc surfer il
quitte l'elysée tout le monde disait
mais de toute façon il est de mèche avec
françois hollande
il prépare le terrain pour lui en fait
titraille et puis finalement son
discours la modernité de son discours la
modernité de son approche les idées
qu'ils lancent même si elles sont pas
pour l'instant financé on est toujours
sur des intentions on attend son projet
ça interpelle c'est intéressant
les jeunes me suivent il a amené un vent
nouveau de l'air frais donc on peut pas
faire comme s'il n'existait pas c'est
pas possible donc on nous on est pas on
est centriste on est appelé à travers
tout le monde
forcément on écoute on étudie on voit je
pense que on va parler avec eux pour
l'instant il n'y a rien de défini
françois sort son livre je dis là le 1er
février résolution française qui est un
programme on va le dire quand même qu'il
ya un projet en tout cas il le sort l'a
donc on sera très exactement ce que le
modem a comme vision pour la france pour
demain emmanuel macron va en dire plus
sur son projet je crois à la fin du mois
je pense que c'est à la fin du mois on
verra un petit peu plus clair en
fonction des positionnements des uns et
des autres on voit que la gauche est
lisse très à gauche avec benoît hamon
à droite on est très à droite avec
françois fillon il ya un espace énorme
et un axe central énorme au milieu qui
est à prendre à conquérir à travailler
et à mener une autre alternative que
celle proposée par le front national
parce que voilà donc la maintenance et
clairement il ya quatre poulains sur le
paysage politique français bien défini
c'est une aubaine benoît hamon désigné
candidat du ps justement c'est pas que
ce soit une aubaine moi j'arrive chez
moi j'ai pas moi j'ai pas été étonnée je
vais vous dire un truc j'étais ravi que
ce soit benoît hamon qui gagnent alors
ça d'un point de vue personnel parce que
je connais l'homme et jeu-là précis mais
je suis pas du tout étonnée de la même
manière que françois fillon a très bien
travaillé son son programme des
primaires en en mettant un programme
très à droite et il a remporté à droite
sur son électorat et c'est normal le nom
a moins fait exactement la même chose à
gauche il a fait un programme de bush on
va pas dire très à gauche il l'a fait à
gauche à ce qu'était le ps d'antan
finalement et il a redonné au ps qu'il
était avant la social-démocratie et bien
voilà des choses sont claires il ya une
gauche qui à gauche il ya une droite qui
à droite et il ya une place au centre
merci à vous
la question de la parité homme-femme
envahi désormais l'espace culturel avec
un nouveau festival féminin pluriel pour
sa première édition ce rendez vous
organisé par le réseau de théâtre
créative propose au public de découvrir
une trentaine de propos de projet est
dirigé artistiquement par une ou
plusieurs femmes
une grande partie de ses représentations
est notamment prévue dans les yvelines
comme nous l'expliquent sabine caussens
coprésident du festival
elle répondait aux questions de camille
lambert nous sommes avec sabine caussens
co présidente du festival féminin
pluriel pour cette première édition est
directrice du prisme bonjour sabine
alors un mot sur ce festival mais tout
d'abord sur ce lieu qui se veut un lieu
symbolique pourquoi avoir choisi l'année
les attributs l'air bien parce que quand
on parle des femmes artistes et qu'on se
pose la question dans les yvelines pour
faire un lancement de festivals et une
conférence de presse qu'elle serait le
lieu emblématique on avait beaucoup de
mal à trouver et c'est avec un grand
plaisir qu'on a trouvé que elsa triolet
donc la femme de louis aragon mais qui a
été le premier prix goncourt en 1945
donc on sidi ben voilà ça c'est une
bonne entrée en matière dans c'est vrai
que ça semble un petit peu loin dans les
campagnes reculées de ce beau
département des yvelines
mais le lieu est magnifique et puis
surtout aussi de couple de louis aragon
qui était lui-même artiste elsa triolet
artistes et 7 cette osmose qu'ils
avaient ce respect l'un de l'autre était
aussi un peu emblématique de la parité
alors un petit peu maintenant sur ce
festival selon vous en avez parlé c'est
sur les ailes et comment dire la place
des femmes dans le milieu artistique
quelle est la raison ce festival c'était
une mise à l'honneur un petit peu alors
au delà d'une mise à l'honneur quand
même donc c'en est une bien entendu mais
le ce qui nous a
amené à aller jusqu'à un événement comme
un festival c'est à dire de fédérer des
projets portés par des femmes et donner
les moyens à ces femmes de présenter
leurs chorégraphies
leur spectacle de musique ou de théâtre
est ce qui était très important c'est
que déjà créative depuis donc est un
réseau de 16 théâtres de villes dans les
yvelines et puis un dans le val d'oise
qui nous rejoint pour l'événement avait
déjà soutenu des projets mais deux à
trois projets par en donnant une petite
part de coproduction à des femmes est
évidemment au bout de trois ans est
venue naturel le dire mais comment
allons nous faire savoir et rendre plus
lisibles ce besoin de d'aider les femmes
dans la production pour qu'il y ait une
meilleure parité fait une question
sociétale qui nous est arrivé
directement à la phase une fois qu'on a
eus fait tout ce travail qui est aussi
notre travail de directeur de lieux de
repérer des talents de repérer des
écritures de donner des chances
quelquefois c'est pas toujours réussis
paix quelquefois hop ça fait des
artistes qui montent et qui commence une
carrière et on s'est rendu compte que
les femmes c'était plus difficile pour
elles que pour les hommes
on avait moins de projets elle avait
moins de budget de production donc très
vite alors mois au prix serait bien
entendu j'en ai soutenu beaucoup mais
également des directeurs ont sauvé les
balles théâtre du vésinet le collectif
12 beaucoup d'entre eux ont répondu à
l'appel
voilà et du coup on s'est rendu compte
en mettant en exergue beaucoup à
l'honneur comme vous voulez la
production féminine puisque à 28 projets
de femmes
on s'est rendu compte qu'on rentrait
dans un vrai sujet sociétal mais on a
refait le chemin nous mêmes donc j'en
étais surpris d'avoir refait le chemin
de même qu'une et à partir de ce moment
là on s'est rendu compte à quel point
tout autour était hyper fragile alors
nous étions déjà adhérents de
l'association achète l'île de france qui
est évidemment partenaire du festival
nous avions eu connaissance des chiffres
du recul d'après le rapport de m plat
prat des directions de lieux des projets
femmes des femmes chefs d'orchestre
et femmes auteurs des auteurs il y en a
des auteurs femmes des auteurs montrent
et il y en a à peine 25%
ça veut dire que quand même il ya 75 %
d'hommes cesu vous même vous le
ressentez justement en tant que
directrice du prisme
oui bien sûr des textes de femmes on en
a pas beaucoup ou alors ils sont
tellement orientée mais je veux dire
c'est qu'on va dire c'est pas naturel
tout ça c'est pas on n'a pas la même
veine c'est pas sur le mont se refait
pas sur la même vague que ce qui est la
création
dites masculines entre guillemets mais
l'idéal c'est ce que disait sophia aram
est ce que disait le collectif des
filles de simone l'idéal serait que ce
festival n'existe pas or nous allons le
faire exister on y est mais toute notre
énergie est ce qu'il faudrait c'est que
il s'arrête
voilà dans deux trois ans un petit mot
sur la programmation comme en été
comment ont été choisis les différents
projets comment comment ça c'est fait il
ya 14 créations donc sur les 28 quand
même et 50% de création ça c'était
important que ça serait des écritures
contemporaines et qu' on est différents
types artistique la danse est
représentée enfin parce que souvent la
dent ça ne va pas beaucoup le théâtre
bien entendu le spectacle jeune public
la chanson avec clarika enfin voilà donc
ça c'était important mais mais on avait
décidé en conseil d'administration qui
aurait quand même un comité pas de
comité de pilotage de programmation pour
vérifier que l'ensemble de tous les
projets qui étaient présentés étaient
bien porté par des femmes et qu'il y
avait des possibilités de budget de
production savoir s'il fallait les
soutenir voilà donc ça a été très
attentif à tout ça et donc ça a donné
cette proposition là qui n'est pas une
sélection qui est une proposition parce
que la palette est énorme
il ya énormément de projets de création
fait par des femmes
alors ce qu'il faut savoir aussi c'est
qu'il ya peu près dans le nombre
d'artistes concernés dans les
distributions dans les chorégraphies et
danseurs on est à peu près à parité
entre hommes et femmes puisque ce qui
est essentiel c'est que soit le projet
qu'ils soient portées par une femme et
un dernier petit mot puisque le public
peut également soutenir ce festival il
ya une la trame de croo funding alors
donc je pense qu'il ya un lien
sur ww créative points mais je ne
prenais pas l'adresse exacte oui parce
que c'était une vraie question sociétale
comme on en a déjà parlé et je pense que
donc h f
ile de france a soutenues par cette
plate sur cette plateforme il ya des
choses importantes
il ya des gens qui sont venus mais
évidemment créative et ben n'a pas
beaucoup de soutiens financiers pour son
fonctionnement
on a perdu une aide départementale qui
était précieuse donc c'est vrai que du
coup pour la communication pour le suivi
des choses on a on s'est dit tiens parce
que c'est une question qui touche tout
le monde peut-être les gens ont envie
d'y participer même très modestement on
savait 10 euros c'est impeccable voilà
ainsi à 100 personnes qui donnent 10
euros c'est parfait on a besoin d'une
personne qui donne santoro sam karmann
et l arrêt on peut tromper une fois
mille personnes et pas mille fois une
personne bombe a seraient bien bas si on
veut soutenir ce projet voilà c'est le
site internet s'affichera en bas de
l'écran
je vous remercie en tout cas sabine que
ça merci beaucoup c'est la fin du set 8
les invités pour ce soir prochaine
édition demain jeudi excellente soirée
sur tv fil 78
[Musique]